if you paid any attention to the
leadership of the Republican Party here
in Washington over the past thirty years
in particular if you pay attention to
what they've done when they've had power
it's clear what they care most about
they care most about cutting taxes for a
higher earners for their donors they
care about helping American companies
ship their jobs overseas or important
foreigners here to work at lower wages
they care about launching wars in
far-off places they've done all of those
things and as they have with the help of
the Democratic Party the American family
has decayed in the middle class along
with it the Republican Party has also
decayed at the same time if Democratic
leaders didn't repeatedly make it clear
how much they despise this country the
people who live in it the Republican
Party are probably dead by now they've
been saved by the extremism of their
opponents but does it have to be this
way what would it look like if the
Republican Party embraced a new agenda
one that included helping American
families form and thrive Johnny Burke
tennis thought a lot about this question
he's the executive editor of the
American Conservative and he joins us
tonight Johnny thanks so much for coming
on so what would a Republican Party that
had American families at its center look
like well Tucker for the past thirty
years as you've noted the Republican
Party has paid a lot of lip service to
families especially around election time
to win votes but they've done very
little to support the bedrock
institution that holds our country and
our economy together America cannot be
great unless the institutions that
support us from the bottom up are strong
these include churches schools
institutions of civil society but most
importantly the family what happens in
the family determines the course of what
happens in someone's life it determines
the course of our culture and the course
of our country and the family in America
today is under siege conservatives have
rightly pointed out a number of areas
for many years like the pernicious
influence of Hollywood the impact of
growing impact of Silicon Valley with
the addictive products they're marketing
to children including pornography today
conservers are finally starting to wake
up to another threat which is malignant
market forces that are undermining our
families now there are many of them one
of them that I like to point out is
crony capitalism now crony capitalism is
I would define it is collusion between
big government and big business at the
expense of the American people it's
pretty easy for someone like Pete Budaj
to graduate from a top school like
Harvard and get a job for a management
consulting firm in Washington making
powerpoints
for a faceless bureaucracy like the
Postal Service or maybe if you're lucky
you know designing powerpoints for a
foreign dictator or pushing pills for
big pharma and to make a six-figure
salary but really what's going on is
that the jobs are being sapped from the
heartland to pad the pockets of a few
politically connected people in
Washington DC and middle America is not
going to tolerate that anymore so is
that middle America that part's the
company that have been most wounded by
these changes the economic changes the
country's gone through a Republican area
is mostly rural America's reliably
Republican and it's dying and the
Republican Party in Washington which is
supposed to be representing it doesn't
seem to notice how does that work well
they've deliberately ignored middle
America because they they counted on
their votes until this recent election
when Wisconsin Pennsylvania Michigan
finally flipped to the Republicans and
they're starting to realize oh wow this
new constituency is a fundamental part
of our base if we want to maintain power
and the trade deals that have decimated
the economies in these places
Republicans are starting to take them
seriously which is why I've been
encouraged that Ivanka Trump at the
White House is putting paid family leave
front and center at the agenda for the
White House they're going to be hosting
a summit on the topic this week and
other members in the Senate like Marco
Rubio have introduced bills Bill Cassidy
and they're starting to talk about
things like common good capitalism
they're starting to look at how
conservatives can support the family
from the bottom up and they're gonna
need to find a way to do this if they
want to be a party that wins at the
ballot box now you're absolutely right
and it's because of intellectual leaders
like you and the publication that you
run that the path for
is clearer than it than it has been in a
long time thank you for that
Johnny great to see you great thanks for
having me Tucker